Wall Street Journal posted a article a
couple months back that is very
interesting why is it so cool to be
gloomy has the percentage of the world's
population that lives in extreme poverty
almost doubled almost halved or stayed
the same over the past 20 years when the
swedish swedish statistician and public
health expert
Hans Rosling began asking people that
question he was astounded by their
responses only 5% of Americans got the
right answer now here's the question
they asked it again has extreme poverty
worldwide been cut in half
doubled or stayed the same in the last
20 years what's the answer well the
actual right answer is extreme poverty
has been cut almost in half
only 5% said that most people said it
doubled a chimp a chimpanzee would do
better if he pointed out mischievously
by picking an answer at random so people
are worse than ignorant they believe
they know many dire things about the
world that are in fact untrue Rosling
published a magnificent book arguing
against such reflexive pessimism fact
fulness ten reasons we're wrong about
the world and why things are are better
than you think they are very interesting
people cling to pessimism about the
state of the world John Stuart Mill mill
neatly summarized this tendency as far
back as 1828 I've observed that not that
not the man who hopes when others
despair but the man who despairs when
others hope is admired by a large class
of persons as a sage
cool to be gloomy the persistence of
pessimism about the planet requires some
explanation beyond just the facts
themselves bad news is more sudden than
good news does good news is generally
gradual therefore bad news is more
newsworthy battles bombings accidents
murders storms floods scandals disasters
tornados all tend to dominate the news
if it bleeds it leads
by contrast the gradual reduction in
poverty in the world rarely makes a
sudden splash as Rosling put it in the
media the newsworthy events exaggerate
the unusual and put the focus on swift
changes another example that if you
think about the stock market the stock
market gradually has gone up for acts
since the crash of o8 at the bottom of
the stock market the Dow was 6300 is
24,000 it's gone up 4x we heard anybody
reporting on that like like America just
won the Super Bowl
no but if you put money in your 401k
through that period of time if you put a
million dollars in in 2008 10 years
later you'd have four million dollars
four times money
and yet when someone's at if you were to
just generally publish and you know just
generally ask people about the stock
market what do they do they answer
pessimistically because they always hear
when it drops largest one-day drop in
history
this year it's all over the front page
of everything you ever hear one largest
one-day increase as the opening line on
the nightly news
never never pessimism is cool and bad
news usually matters good news may not
matter
people think in relative terms not
absolute terms which means they their
critical thinking skills are screwed as
the world improves people expand their
definition of bad news you know if you
think about the Black Plague you know we
do not have a situation anywhere in the
world today where entire populations 25%
of the population is dead and piled up
in the streets due to disease we do not
have that as a worldwide epidemic I mean
you think about polio you think about
the number of people that died before
some simple antibiotics and penicillin
but nobody talks about that everybody's
like Zika what happened to Zika by the
way where'd it go
I mean we went through a period of time
all my daughter's were just completely
freaked out that Zika might invade
Tennessee it's gone
did anybody report that it was gone the
CDC no longer has any warnings on Zika
remember Zika deformed babies everywhere
remember that mosquitoes will kill you
mosquitoes will kill your kids remember
it's just I mean I'm not saying it
wasn't real but no one noticed when it
disappeared because we tend to be in the
human race gloomy pessimistic too many
people are a glass half empty instead of
a glass half full and so you really have
to fight against that to do proper
analysis proper critical thinking skills
policy issues but also just about your
personal finance about your job
many people make wrong financial
decisions because they have a persistent
worry that they're going to get laid off
and never have been that the economy is
going to crash so I'm going to buy gold
bars which is really stupid by the way
or the American currency is going to
fail so I'm going to put my
grandfather's inheritance that he worked
his whole life for in Bitcoin which if
you look up stupid in the dictionary
you'll see your picture really let's see
we you have to make these set of sets of
gloomy doomsday assumptions in order to
make these moves well you really can't
get ahead out there the little guy I
mean maybe years ago in America you
could have got ahead but the little guy
can't get ahead and yet the research
that we just did on millionaires here
with Chris Hogan and our research team
shows that 79% of our of the largest
study millionaires ever done 79 percent
of millionaires in America inherited
nothing five percent inherited less than
a hundred thousand which mathematically
means they did not become millionaires
because matter of fact another five
percent inherited less than two hundred
thousand and most of those inheritance
were after they were already had a
million dollar net worth because the
average millionaire that we talked to
had a two point eight million dollar net
worth by the way in the ten thousand
that we studied so here's the thing nine
out of ten eighty nine percent of
millionaires did not and did not become
wealthy because of an inheritance they
did some 10 percent them did inherit
some money 97 percent of them say they
believe that control their own destinies
when we interviewed the public sixty-two
percent said they believe they control
their own destinies seventy percent of
millionaires set aside some of their
income every month to be given to others
it's hard to be generous when you're
gloomy gloomy will make you selfish
because you have to hold on to it you
have to hoard it because bad times are
coming when you live a life of abundance
instead of scarcity generosity is a lot
easier changes everything well you have
to you know you have to be a doctor to
be a millionaire you have to be a NFL
player to be a millionaire know the top
three jobs were engineer accountant and
teacher among America's millionaires
this is all in the book every day
millionaires number one bestseller by
Chris Hogan 140 statistics in there it
is not a research paper it's an
inspiring inspiring book and you'll
enjoy it because it'll tell you that
there's no need to be glowing gloomy the
American Dream is not dead did you hear
me I've statistically proven it the
American Dream is alive and well we are
Americans not Americans